répugnait souvent aux exercices du corps
ses muscles dur d'être disciplinés
l'école de joinville est passée par là
la france est un empire est un film
documentaire qui pendant 1h30 détail les
multiples bienfaits de la colonisation
sans la moindre autocritique
nous sommes en 1939 le moment n'est pas
encore venu
ça représente parfois plusieurs dizaines
de films par an en france le film
coloniale qui va aller des années disons
des années 20 aux années 50
ça va durer un petit peu encore après
guerre mais la grande période entre
guillemets avec tous les guillemets
qu'il faut du film coloniale c'est
véritablement le milieu des et la fin
des années 30
donc on est devant un film d'un genre
qui est tout à fait constitué j'irai
renoir parlait du genre coloniale
presque comme le western la française
c'est cette idée voilà des terres
vierges qu'on va conquérir que on va
voilà et qu'on va offrir en quelque
sorte à la civilisation
les indigènes n'hésitent plus à confier
leur fillette à l'école
instruite comme les gares dont elle fait
partie d'être comme sous la loi barbare
les inférieur promise au plus rudes
travaux nous ce colonialisme cette
justification du polonais est difficile
à supporter mais il se trouve que vous
savez peut-être jean zay donc insisté
pour que ce film soit dans la sélection
pourquoi parce que
qu'est ce qu'on y montrer le titre est
très explicite la france est à nos pairs
elle a désarmé
elle a des troupes c'est un message
subliminal envoyé à l'allemagne en
particulier
si vous avise de faire la guerre il n'y
a pas seulement les troupes de la
métropole mais il ya toutes les forces
de l' empire et donc ça représente une
force militaire considérable
jean zay savait que la guerre risquait
d'arriver et dans ce contexte il a conçu
le festival de cannes comme une machine
politique destinée à vanter les mérites
du monde libre contre le totalitarisme
son voir qu'en même temps il faisait la
promotion d'un autre totalitarisme mais
des organisateurs ont choisi de ne pas
occulter le problème posé par les films
coloniaux il faut les voir il faut
absolument les montres et il faut les
regarder pour comprendre quelles étaient
les mentalités de l'époque mais il faut
les présenter comme des documents et du
coup les montrer comme des documents
historiques c'est à dire faut les
accompagner oui bien sûr nation